how did the Arsenal weapons use in the
fatal attacks in Paris Fortnum's the
hands of terrorists the question is
feeling the charge to better regulate
the sale of firearms that you use
executor wants to stop two types of
semi-automatic weapons being sold to
civilians and to make sure that
deactivated guns found so easily online
cannot be put back together and reuse as
they were in Paris better traceability
and an eu-wide database apart of
proposals presented to mep s on monday
this is ken Forsch like Assante worth of
the direct opposite like this I cheerful
fatin CEO bed imp Adolfo ninh ly guy
laughing casita proposals to the
firearms directive will not for now
tackle black-market trade especially
military-grade weapons although the
Commission was quick to point out that
the ban on certain types of
semi-automatic weapons would catch
Kalashnikovs within the net we need to
make sure that we are cracking down on
illegal use of weapons the weapons that
were allowed to get out into the hands
of terrorists and cause those events in
Paris and elsewhere questions are also
being raised over the so-called
punishment of legal gun owners and
especially the right of hunters and
sport is you have a tradition of using
hunting rifles and next steps Parliament
will now initiate its own report on gun
control as the charge to fight terror
continues